– Wie lange lernen Sie schon Deutsch?
– Ich lerne seit ein Jahre Deutsch.
– Seit einem Jahr.
– Richtig. Ich weiß,
dass man das so sagt, aber …
– Sprechen Sie auch andere Sprachen?
– Ich spreche Arabisch und Armenisch.
– Sie sprechen Armenisch?
– Meine Mutter ist zweisprachig
aufgewachsen.
– Wow.
– Das ist bei uns normal.
– Sprechen Sie auch Englisch?
– Ich habe schon [einen]
Kurs besucht in Syrien.
Aber leider spreche ich
nicht so gut Englisch.
Ich weiß aber, dass Englisch [eine]
wichtige Sprache ist.
– Welche Sprachen lernt ihr denn
in der Schule?
– Bei uns lernt man Englisch und
Französisch in der Schule.
– Du sprichst Französisch?
– Leider sprech ich
nur ein bisschen Französisch.
Aber ich kann ganz gut
Englisch sprechen.
– Verstehe.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass du die
B2-Sprachprüfung bestehst.
– Echt?
– Echt.
– Ich möchte auf jeden Fall studieren!
– Ich finde auch, dass du studieren
solltest. Du schaffst das!
Für welches Studienfach
interessierst du dich?
– Ich weiß nicht.
Vielleicht studier ich …
Medizin oder ich werde Lehrerin, wie du.
– Ja, du hast ja noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Wir sehen uns morgen?
– Ja!
Danke, Lisa, für deine Hilfe.
– Das mach ich doch gern.